yeah being mad at basketball um it
happened just so quickly so suddenly i
was on top of my game i was trying to
redefine who i was
um i even talked to pat riley and we
were you know a couple months ago and we
were talking about at the time when
i had to
retire pretty much or you know had to
stop playing
i felt we were a championship contending
team not to say we would have won but
you know when you get there and you're
successful all you know all you got to
do is get back and focus
and you take you know you take what
comes your way
um you know not having that chance i was
a bit bitter at that
you know just having it in so suddenly
and but still feeling and knowing that
i'm one of the best players in the world
for sure top 20.
you know why no no that having to deal
with that i i just had to
go through those things go through those
stages of grief realize where i was and
eventually you know be appreciative of
it you know you were talking about
connections one of me and my close
friends josh mcroberts we both
lost the game at the same time we were
both i think i was 31 at the time he was
like 29.
and and you know just to hear someone
you know people would say oh yeah that
guy bob he always getting hurt he can't
help it if he gets hurt nobody says i'm
gonna sign a four-year deal and be hurt
every year and never play
the game that i've always done in my
whole life ever again yeah you know but
that's where we kind of connected
accepting those things and
i realized that that is more often the
fate
of uh of someone in our profession so
you know i was even having a
conversation with a friend i said it
didn't end i was so frustrated said it
didn't end the way that i wanted it to
he said dude it never does
he took all the wind out of my cell
because i wanted to argue
no i've i heard some good advice at one
point it was like when you're talking to
somebody and they have an issue you
should maybe clear up early on if they
just want to vent or if they want a
solution
because yeah you'll probably get a real
answer even if they're like man i just
want to talk and you're like great
because i have the problem where i like
to solve problems and so somebody comes
to me with an issue i'm like all right
what are you doing about it you know
like
sometimes they just want to get it off
their chest you know yeah and i'm sure
that's where you were at to some degree
is like you know you kind of just want
to get it off your chest and you know
you feel a little trapped in the
emotions
for sure
uh actually i have one question before i
ask something a little bit deeper but
you know as a as a sports fan and i am a
sports fan all sports um
you know you look at players and you and
you you know you think are you really
injured
like come on did you stub your toe
because you really need to sit out and
um you know i've judged you know being
from chicago
judged like you know bears quarterbacks
or i've judged you know
um you know the bulls when uh you know
uh
rose was on the team and i was like you
know just like people like that and
you're like oh come on get out there and
play so truly what is the what what
happens that makes a player
not be able to play the game whose
decision is it and how bad is it and is
it a short term yes or is it kind of
like a long term like we can't let this
get worse and i'm sure there's a range
of it but what's the general reason
i think you know you know well i mean
the answer is different now now you have
um terms like um load management
to where some guys will probably take a
day of rest and not play
um you'll have old school nba players
that will disagree with that heavily
uh because you know we were all about
pushing through
the pain and all those things
i came to have more of a realization how
much
medicine and doctors play into athletes
once i started having my decision or or
not my my um
what i was going through but i'll put it
to you like this one of my uh i had a
teammate at once upon a time
he um
he he injured his back
and he had you know
surgery on his back years later he has a
toe problem
then he has um surgery on his toe
now
could he have stayed was it the right
procedure that was right for him i can't
tell you but
he
progressed quicker than everybody
thought he would he goes to camp
starts the season gets hurt two months
later
you know now it's nothing that he did i
mean is
he's just trying to play the game but
his body is telling okay he's you know
something's wrong and then after i've
had another teammate who he kept
breaking his foot
like the metatarsal just would go one
first metatarsal third fourth fifth
right after he broke the other one you
know so sometimes it can just be this
chain reaction that you can never
really come back from and with that said
i mean for me i've played with sprained
ankles sprained knees
and then you know i've told people hey
don't wait till you come back no not you
know that's not the case sometimes you
have to make a decision i mean even for
me i tore my groin i told him tore my
adductor muscle in the pursuit of our
first championship
and i didn't tell anybody i just said
okay
you know the doctors told me in three
weeks maybe you can play with pain
that's all i needed to hear because i
had my goals
you know was the best thing can't tell
you we won the championship
i didn't make any excuses i didn't want
to say ah well you know
if i would have been playing if my
leg was i know nobody cares so for me i
had to be you know i had to make that
decision to i guess sacrifice my body a
little bit to go out there
and help this team win and at the same
time you know i had to have that moment
of truth and saying okay no this is this
is this isn't it this our destiny is
winning this thing and i've got to be
healthy or
you know or at least play uh to win you
know is it always ultimately up to the
athlete or does the team make executive
decisions
i think more so now the team is more of
in a a place to make executive decisions
more so than than before i think before
um you know we've had many athletes
whether they they were mentally not
ready emotionally not ready physically
not ready they played and i think um
we've seen some kind of the detriment um
that it could bring so i think now
um
the league sports i think everyone is a
little more proactive
in trying to preserve health or at least
injuries and not pushing the player too
much like a part of that also is
motivation right because like you wanted
to win the championship so like your
motivation exceeded the pain how do you
what what was your motivation let's
start there i'm curious like especially
when it comes to the the saying of
you know are you is it the fear of
losing or is it the love of winning like
if you had to pick one of those to start
with which one would you pick the fear
of losing or the love of winning
i i picked the fear of losing for sure
funny story um i used to play i started
playing basketball when i was like nine
years old
and it was a you know very historic
place in south dallas uh catholic school
which every saturday they would have
what's called bitty basketball it's a
lead 10 and under biddy basketball
league and if you were any good player
out of dallas you played there it's like
the mecca of youth
uh basketball and we had a team
i was in the fourth grade i was playing
up
and
we would lose
quite often i mean if it was another
team that went 0 and 10 in the league we
were 2 and 8 because we could only beat
them you know what i mean
and every game that we lost pretty much
and i mean it kind of stayed with me
until around the seventh or eighth grade
i would cry i would cry i mean
it hurt me
like
just a little like a loss in the family
every time i couldn't help it
and um you know i know my parents were
probably just like you're shaking you're
like ah damn man this guy
but that's just
you know i wanted to be like my heroes
um i watched michael jordan win a lot of
championships and he was still winning
and i just wanted just a p is just a
taste
just a little just what is it like on
that small level just as that would be a
great saturday
if we could just win a game you know and
i just put my all into it
and
yeah i guess i learned how
competitive i was and how much i cared
you know and i guess ever since then it
was more so
i love winning don't get me wrong but
yeah that
that fear you know and that's what i
took into
uh my professional career
and i don't want to you know make fear a
negative thing it just is what it is
that fear of losing is like okay
let me watch another hour of film
everybody
you know
let's go back to the gym yeah let me i
always found confidence and preparation
so
i felt if i was prepared if i felt if i
knew my assignment
if i felt i knew i was physically ready
emotionally ready ready to go um that
always gave me confidence and then
there's a motive playing the game my
worries were always in between the big
games playing the game is no problem you
know it gets stressful sure it's playing
basketball it's that time in between
where
you know you have to keep it cool and
keep it even for like three days
you know
you